TUCKER?
>> Tucker: MATT FINN, FROM
CHICAGO.
THANKS A LOT FOR THAT WELL,
EVEN KIM FOXX ACKNOWLEDGES
SHE BELIEVES JUSSIE SMOLLETT
IS GUILTY OF FAKING A HATE
CRIME BUT THE ACTOR WILL
STILL NOT ADMIT THAT.
INSTEAD, HIS LAWYER SAYS THE
AS
DOORND MAY HAVE PUT ON WHITE
FACE.
>> HE BELIEVED HIS ATTACKERS
WERE WHITE.
HE SAID THEY HAD MASKS ON
AND GLOVES AND HE SAW THEIR
EYES AND HE SAW THE SKIN
SURROUNDING THEIR EYES.
WAS THAT A FALSE STATEMENT?
>> OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN
DISGUISE THAT AND PUT MAKEUP
ON IT TOOK ME ALL OF FIVE
MINUTES TO GOOGLE I WAS
LOOKING UP THE BROTHERS AND
ONE OF THE FIRST VIDEOS THAT
SHOWED UP WAS ONE OF THE
BROTHERS IN WHITE FACE DOING
A JOKESTER MONOLOGUE WITH
WHITE MAKEUP ON.
IT'S NOT THAT IMPLAUSIBLE.
>> Tucker: NOT IMPLAUSIBLE.
IS IT IMPLAUSIBLE?
LORI SMITH IS AN ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING THOSE BROTHERS
AND SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
GLORIA, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
YOU HEARD THAT SUGGESTION
THAT YOUR CLIENTS, WITHOUT
THE KNOWLEDGE OF JUSSIE
SMOLLETT, ATTACKED HIM WHILE
WEARING WHITE FACED MAKEUP.
DID THEY?
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT'S PREPOSTEROUS ON TOP
OF MORE RIDICULOUSNESS FOR
HER TO COME OUT AND SAY THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT?
OF COURSE ANYTHING IS
POSSIBLE IN THAT WORLD.
BUT, PROBABLE?
NO.
>> Tucker: SO DO YOUR
CLIENTS, THESE BROTHERS,
CONCEDE THAT THEY WERE PART
OF THIS HOAX?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY HAVE COOPERATED,
TUCKER, FROM DAY ONE.
I MEAN, THEIR MAIN FOCUS WAS
ALWAYS TO NOT BE PART OF A
FRAUD.
AND, YOU KNOW, TUCKER, IF
YOU LOOK AT THE VERY LITTLE
MEDIA THAT THEY HAVE DONE
AND THE RELEASES THAT WE
HAVE MADE, THEY HAVE
APOLOGIZED FOR THEIR ROLE
AND THEY FEEL TREMENDOUSLY
REGRETFUL FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THIS.
>> Tucker: SO WERE THEY
EMPLOYED BY --
>> -- WE ARE WAITING ON
THAT -- I'M SORRY, GO AHEAD.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
WERE THEY EMPLOYED BY
SMOLLETT, I READ THAT ONE OF
THEM HAD WORKED FOR THE
SHOW, HAD WORKED FOR HIS
SHOW AND THEY HAD WORKED FOR
HIM IN SOME CAPACITY; IS
THAT CORRECT?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
REMEMBER, THAT THERE WAS A
FRIENDSHIP.
THEY HAD MET ON SETS.
THEY HAD KNOWN EACH OTHER
FOR, YOU KNOW, NOT MORE THAN
A YEAR.
SO, THEY REALLY PUT THEIR
TRUST IN SOMEONE WHO THEY
THOUGHT WAS THEIR FRIEND.
SOMEONE WHO HAD INFLUENCE,
SOMEONE WHO COULD, YOU KNOW,
MAKE A GAME CHANGE FOR THEM
IN THEIR CAREER.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT.
AND WE ARE SEEING THAT IN
THE NEWS ON VARIOUS
DIFFERENT FRONTS.
PEOPLE PUTTING THEIR TRUST
IN THE WRONG PERSON AND THE
WORST OF HOLLYWOOD.
>> Tucker: SO THEY FOLLOW
HIS LEAD, THEY TAKE MONEY
FROM HIM IN ORDER TO PULL
OFF THIS FAKE HOAX.
THEY GET CAUGHT, SO DOES
SMOLLETT, HE BLAMES THEM FOR
IT.
AND LIES ABOUT IT AND THEN
BEATS ALL THE CHARGES.
WHAT DO THEY MAKE OF THAT?
>> HERE'S THE THING ABOUT
THE AS
THE DS
THE DO YOU
THE.DO YOU
OWE SUN
DOE SUN
DO YSUN
DO YOUN
OS YOUN
OSUNOUN
OSUNDAN
OSUNDAIRO FAMILY.
THEY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THEY WERE NOT PART OF THAT
FRAUD.
THEIR VALUE SYSTEM CAME OUT
WHILE THEY WERE IN CUSTODY
AND THEY WENT THROUGH A
RELATION PROCESS THAT WHAT
JUSSIE WANTED TO DO WAS TEAR
PEOPLE APART MORE, NOT BRING
THEM TOGETHER.
AND ONE OF THE FIRST
STATEMENTS WE RELEASED
ACTUALLY WE SAID THAT THAT
THEY WERE NOT HOMOPHOBIC.
THEY WERE NOT RACIST.
AND THAT THEY WERE NOT
ANTI-TRUMP.
>> WHAT DO THEY THINK THE
MOTIVE FOR THIS WAS?
HAVE THERE HAVE BAN BUNCH OF
EXPLANATIONS WHY DO THEY
THINK SMOLLETT DID THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, AND I HATE TO
NOT ANSWER A QUESTION ON
YOUR SHOW, TUCKER,
TRUTHFULLY, THE MOTIVES AND
THEIR INTENTIONS, THEIR
FEELINGS, THINGS THAT GO TO
THOSE THINGS I THINK WILL BE
BETTER SAID FROM THEM.
AND WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT,
THEY WILL COME OUT AND SAY
THEIR STORY.
IT'S JUST NOT THE RIGHT
TIME.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE THEY
ARE WELCOME HERE ANY TIME IT
GOES WITHOUT SAYING.
FINALLY, DO THEY FACE ANY
LEGAL JEOPARDY AT ALL?
ARE THEY DONE WITH THIS
PROCESS?
>> THEY ARE DONE.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WELL, NOW
ARE THEY GOING TO GET
INVESTIGATED?
ARE THEY LOOKING AT
CO-CONSPIRACY CHARGES?
YOU CAN'T BE A
CO-CONSPIRATOR TO SOMETHING
THAT IS NOT ILLEGAL.
SO, TUCKER, FOR EXAMPLE, IF
I ASKED YOU TO GO OUT TO THE
STREET AND PUT A NOOSE
AROUND MY NECK WHICH I WOULD
NEVER ASK YOU TO DO THAT.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.
>> IF I HAD, THAT'S NOT
ILLEGAL.
THAT'S JUST NOT ILLEGAL BUT
CALLING THE POLICE AND
SAYING THAT SOMEBODY DID,
THAT IS ILLEGAL MY CLIENTS
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING ILLEGAL.
>> WHITE FACE TO BEAT UP
BOSS WITHOUT HIS KNOWLEDGE.
THANKS FOR CLARIFYING THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> THANK YOU FOR LAUGHING.
BECAUSE IT'S WORTH LAUGHING